un pomeriggio
sì io racconto storie diciamo di lavoro
ben fatto e di uso consapevole delle
tecnologie lo faccio secondo una
modalità che cerca di unire questa
piccola innovazione con la tradizione
non i numeri della tombola napoletana o
scelta dieci numeri
adesso a un certo punto si riprenderanno
e ha un significato reale cercherò di
illustrare di rendere un po più dinamico
questo mio racconto il primo numero del
genio e per caso e il numero uno il
numero uno nella tomba dell'italia e io
racconto l'italia che mi piace l'italia
del lavoro ben fatto all'italia che
pensa lavoro dunque sono
merito rispetto considerazione l'italia
che sposta l'ago della bussola da
riconoscimento sociale della ricchezza
al riconoscimento sociale del lavoro
dall importanza di ciò che sia
all'importanza di ciò che si sa e si sa
fare è un'italia che c'è l'italia che
vorrei lasciare ai miei figli
e l'italia che esiste che tanta io sono
dieci anni che la racconta è fatta di
donne e di uomini che mettono sempre
qualcosa di sé nelle cose che fanno e
provano soddisfazione a farlo bene il
secondo numero del lavoro perché anche
al tempo di internet il lavoro cambia ma
rimane comunque è parte essenziale della
dignità del rispetto dell'identità
dell'autonomia delle persone la via per
cogliere e moltiplicare opportunità
il lavoro ben fatto nasce da qui
dall'idea che ciò che va quasi bene non
va bene da nuto che dice ad anguilla
nella luna ei falò di cesare paris che
ignorante non si conosce da quello che
fa ma da come lo fa
dalla convinzione che fare le cose bene
non è solo bello giusto interessante
conviene se vogliamo fare un esempio
cuciniamo un paio un piatto di pasta e
patate ok per fare la pasta e patate ci
vogliono per farla bene buona e per
farla cattiva
ci vogliono 35 40 minuti
ci vuole la pasta ci vuole la voglia ci
vogliono le patate ci vogliono le spezie
ci vuole l'acqua ci vuole il fuoco ci
vuole la pendola ci vuole il sapone per
lavare la vendola ci vuole il tempo che
la nostra risorsa più preziosa che cos'è
che dà senso a questa rosa
il fatto che noi cerchiamo di cucinare
la pasta migliore la più buona pasta e
patate del mondo non la numero 2 o la
decima la numero 1 che naturalmente
diciamo non riguarda il risultato come
effettivamente sarà la pasta e patate
perché quella dipende da tante cose però
riguarda l'approccio nell'approccio non
posso neanche immaginare di fare la
pasta e patate che viene al secondo
posto al terzo posto se ci devo mettere
comunque 35 40 minuti e devo utilizzare
tutti quegli ingredienti più il tempo
più il sapore più l'acqua più fuoco come
vedete la mia idea è semplice come le
cose semplici però possiede anche una
sua arma mia una sua bellezza raccontate
persone che quando cercano di fare che
quando fanno una cosa cercano di farla
bene progettare l'air burbridge di
sydney insegnate una scuola di provincia
consegnate un telegramma fare un
trapianto di cuore
lavare i pavimenti la sera prima di
abbassare la saracinesca del bar a
partire dalle persone cerchiamo di
coinvolgere le scuole associazioni
comunità che è più complicato però anche
quello diciamo si riesce a fare il pezzo
numero abbiamo visto lungo all'italia il
9 e il lavoro
il pezzo numero e 65 il racconto perché
la fonda importante perché raccontando
storie ci prendiamo cura di noi diamo
forme al trascorrere del tempo
incrementiamo il valore sociale delle
organizzazioni della comunità delle reti
con cui interagiamo attiviamo processi
di innovazione
le storie che raccontiamo ci aiutano a
comprendere ciò che accade a indicare
cause e conseguenze a tenere assieme
quello che sappiamo con quello che è
ipotizzato a parlare di cose assenti e
connette con bossi presenti a vantaggio
del significato a costruire database
dell'esperienza e qui arriva il 41 il 41
il coltello
il coltello è la mia tecnologia
esemplificativa preferita mi piace la
complicità che scorgo negli sguardi nei
volti dei bambini ma anche degli adulti
quando mi ascoltano quando arrivano che
col coltello ci si può tagliare il pane
ma poi fa anche male del male a una
persona perché le tecnologie che ci
cambiano la vita
non sono né buoni né cattivi e l'uso che
ne facciamo che fa la differenza
ora immagino che molti di voi stiano
pensando ma questo è banale no no no no
no no no non lo è non è banale non lo è
nella famiglia media italiana non è
nella scuola media italiana non è tra le
donne non è tra le donne e gli uomini di
ogni età che affollano gli eserciti
della lockdown e generation
in ogni caso il coltello è solo un punto
di partenza una maniera per introdurre
internet mutamento di paradigma che esso
avvenga ha determinato perché il
coltello e una tecnologia internet è una
tecnologia
un modo per dire che le nuove tecnologie
hanno dando più senso sono tanto più
messaggere di possibilità quando leusse
quanto più le usiamo in modo civico e
consapevole quando più ci aiutano a
sviluppare il nostro senso critico ad
essere autori e non solo consumatori di
contenuti a disegnare futuri più averti
inclusivi più plurali il numero
successiva e la iii e il 3 la scuola
molti di noi l'abbiamo sperimentato
l'innovazione non è quasi mai figlia
dell'atto creativo di un momento alle
spalle una storia una storia che la
produce
la compagna la consolida la diffonde
ecco direi che nell'italia del lavoro
ben fatto la scuola ha un ruolo molto
importante anche da questo punto di
vista sul progetto lavoro ben fatto e
uso civico dei media attualmente nella
mia città stiamo lavorando con una prima
elementare a soccavo una seconda e una
terza di un istituto tecnico a scampia
un corso all'università solo benincasa e
un'alfa blood napoli nuovi cantieri
stanno per aprire a ponticelli dove fino
a giugno
a gennaio a giugno scorso abbiamo
lavorato con una quinta a porchiano in
un istituto comprensivo a calata proprio
di gino in un istituto alberghiero
usiamo il lavoro ben fatto le tecnologie
racconto per comprendere la possibilità
è l'importanza di essere più consapevoli
più creativi più capaci di dialogare ed
interagire di esprimere idee e pensieri
in modo sistematico di collaborare e
così a un certo punto
scopriamo che discutere più importante
di obbedire e che fare domande viene
prima di dare risposta il numero
successivo e 72 la meraviglia la
meraviglia mi permette di raccontare del
ragazzo di quinta elementare che mentre
parliamo di spazio curvo e di rotazione
della terra intorno al sole
alza la mano e dice maestro ho capito ho
capito e come con gli scivoli
dell'acquapark non sei tu che puoi fare
tutte quelle giravolte sono loro che te
le fanno fare questo ragazzino fece a 10
anni
la bimba di prima elementare a soccavo
che non s'è ancora leggere e scrivere è
che però con il telefonino della maestra
intervista la signora della refezione e
le chiede c'è il suo lavoro dei piace e
cosa sognava di fare da piccola
i ragazzi di scuola di seconda e terza
del galileo ferraris di scampia li
dovete vedere alla prima alle prese con
la carta dei diritti di internet perché
loro stanno facendo un videogioco su
uomini e macchine lo scratch e quindi
diciamo magari l'anno prossimo ve lo
portiamo qui ma hanno bisogno di capire
in giro le idee che ci stanno dietro la
carta dei diritti di internet
la ragazza del suo russo che scrive la
bio e in un giorno e mezzo la legano più
di mille persone
i corsisti del fab lab e napoli che
scoprono l'importanza di essere story
teller mentre imparano a modellati
entrati a diventare artigiani digitali è
il momento del 18 la città la città del
lavoro ben fatto
pensate come sarebbe bello un arrivo in
una città roncade va benissimo come
esempio e trova il castello benvenuti e
affrontate la città dove ognuno fa bene
quello che deve fare e tutti vivono
meglio ora certo all'inizio è soltanto
un cartello però poi può diventare un
progetto da portare nelle scuole e poi
un'attività di narrazione che coinvolge
alle persone alle strutture di roncade
che quando fanno una cosa la fanno bene
e poi può diventare andor un approccio
condiviso un modo di essere e di fare
una cultura enumera successiva il 67
futuro avere futuro importante
e l'italia allunga l'ombra del futuro
sul presente sia individua e metti in
gamba energie per ripensarci sure fare
un salto prima di tutto culturale per
ridefinire all'essenziale mi dispiace se
torniamo un attimo alla scuola sto
scoprendo che i ragazzi più pc più
piccini hanno una percezione del futuro
sostanzialmente luminosa positiva
gioiosa sembrare i nostri bimbi siano
designer di un mondo nel quale le
tecnologie sono orientate al bene bello
un mondo senza multirischi e paure ora
immagino che molti di voi stiano
pensando che poi purtroppo si cresce
bisogna fare i conti con la realtà
in parte è vero ma basta questo a
spiegare perché l'energia positiva di
questi bambini a un certo punto si
appanna si perde e proprio inevitabile
che il coltello che secondo paolo di 10
anni è stata inventata per tagliare il
salame possa diventare un'arma per
uccidere una persona
io credo di no per questo lavoro per una
scuola che alimenta sogna immaginazione
che educa alla consapevolezza al
pensiero plurale e critico che
incrementa il patrimonio di bellezza e
di fiducia verso il futuro
il gol di cui i nostri piccoli principi
sono portatori io penso questo cerco di
anche di reagire di conseguenza
48 la pazienza la pazienza ha
conquistato un posto tra le parole della
mia vita alla fine degli anni 90 degli
anni 90 grazie a giorgio gaber che nel
corso di una causa di una conferenza
all'istituto italiano per gli studi
filosofici affermò che se avesse dovuto
di assumere l'intero novecento in due
sole parole pensate
c'è una persona così grande che immagina
solo di poter pensare di raccontare un
secolo in due parole le due parole che
lui scelse che ci indicò erano pazienza
e lavoro
ora il lavoro e abilità io lo portavo lo
porto con me da sempre pazienza invece
fu una rivelazione
oggi proverà a riassumerla così va bene
che facciamo mille rossa va bene che
siamo multitasking per pensieri ha
bisogno anche di profondità di fuga di
tempo tempo inteso non solo come kronos
ma anche come dare rosso come occasione
e aggiungere che questo bisogno di
profondità di cura e di tempo non
riguarda solo il pensiero ma anche
l'azione soprattutto quando mettiamo in
campo azioni civiche plurali 79 il sogno
arrivati qui il mio sogno lo conoscete e
l'italia del lavoro ben fatto sud italia
fatta di città ben fatte di scuole ben
fatte di classe dirigenti ben fatte ora
voi dite è una parola e beh se fosse
facile non sarebbe un sogno però lo
sappiamo come funziona quando si sogna
da soli è un sogno quando si sogna in
due ha inizio la realtà e mi piace
l'idea di ridurre lo spazio della
sognare la realtà di definendo
l'essenziale quello che viene prima e
quello che viene dopo l'ordine di
priorità
è un proprio come con lastre band di
faust solo con il segno in più con il
segno più perché noi vogliamo
condividere e moltiplicare bellezza un
so civico delle tecnologie lavoro ben
fatto innovazione mio padre era un
operaio e mi ripeteva spesso c'è una
doccia nel sacco non fa rumore
tante invece si aveva ragione su questo
come su tante altre cose bisogna essere
in tanti per fare switch off per operare
la svolta per mettere in moto processi
di somari fismo per far diventare il
sogno una narrazione diffusa una cultura
un approccio condiviso
ora i miei numeri sono finite la mia
voglia di fare qualcosa per cambiare
d'italia invece no
anche se la fatica è tanta io non riesco
a fare a meno di questa voglia
il fatto è che la sera quando metto la
testa sopra il cuscino sono contento e
credetemi è bellassai grazie